hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein
cookie rezept und ich sage euch dieses
rezept ist schneller fertig gebacken als
wenn ihr jetzt zum supermarkt laufen und
welche kaufen das anstehen an der kasse
hallo und es gute ist er hat nur zutaten
die mit sicherheit zu hause habt ihr
habe ich zumindest immer da und ich habe
auch ein paar austauschbare zutaten das
zeige ich euch später alles und ich
zeige euch erstmal die zutaten und zwar
benötigen wir mehl backpulver weiche
butter 1 ei und dann könnt euch
aussuchen schoko drops entweder die
runden oder eckigen oder aber auch
kuvertüre außerdem braunen zucker
vanillezucker und eine prise salz und
jetzt müssen wir uns den teig zusammen
dafür gebe ich die weiche butter in
meiner ausreichend große schüssel und
wer mag kann hier zum beispiel auch
margarine benutzen
den braunen zucker habe ich auch schon
reingetan daneben jetzt noch
vanillezucker rhein und die prise salz
hebt nämlich nochmal den süßen geschmack
und jetzt benutze ich mein handrührgerät
weil ich denke dass viele von euch auch
ein handrührgerät da haben und da müssen
wir nicht extra die küchenmaschine
anschmeißen das wird jetzt ungefähr zwei
minuten dann richtig schön cremig
gerührt
[Musik]
so nachdem die butter zucker mischung
richtig schön cremig aufgeschlagen wurde
dem wir das ei mit hinzu falls es auch
die vollkommen sollte ob ihr den braunen
zucker ersetzen könnt das könnt ihr da
könnt ihr einfach weißen zu können aber
brown das stück einfach viel besser das
habe ich jetzt ganz kurz eingerührt bis
sich das ganze gut verbunden hat als
nächstes werden backpulver und mehl ganz
kurz und grob zusammengerührt und zur
masse gegeben
gerne auch in einem schwung kurz
einarbeiten und dann ist der teig schon
fast fertig
der basis teig für die cookies ist jetzt
schon fertig und deswegen so schnell in
der zeit ich hatte meine schuld meine
jacke angezogen und wer lust zum
supermarkt und jetzt geben wir unsere
schoko drops hinein ihr könnt da
entscheiden vollmilch zartbitter weiße
schokolade geht auch falls ihr keine
schoko drop start geht zum beispiel eine
tafel schokolade einfach fein hacken und
in die masse untergehen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich nur ein backblech geholt
da eine dauer back folie oder ein
backpapier drauf gegeben da könnt ihr
selbst entscheiden und jetzt gebe ich
den teig darüber wichtig ist dass wir
den abstand last weil die werden noch
breit und die gehen richtig auf und ich
nehme es entweder zwei teelöffel und
gibt den teig dann so drauf oder was wir
auch machen könnt falls ihr sohn einst
portionierer zu hause habt dann habt ihr
auch immer gleichmäßig große kekse
einmal abstreifen und dann auch auf
backpapier geben
[Musik]
und ich gebe immer gerne erstmal nur
sechs cookies auf ein backblech und
backen dafür lieber zweimal oder sogar
dreimal weil ich finde es ganz wichtig
dass nicht viel abstand haben damit sie
sind ja nicht so zusammenkleben und ich
dir jetzt in den backofen vorgeheizt
ganz wichtig 170 grad ober und
unterhitze so ungefähr 15 bis 18 minuten
so ihr lieben meine cookies sind fertig
ich zeige euch meinen ganz kurz den
unterschied also was eine minute offen
so ausmacht hier haben wir einen den
habe ich 16 minuten lang offen gehabt
und jetzt zeige ich euch ein den ich 15
minuten lang im ofen habt habt da könnt
ihr selber entscheiden was ihr lieber
mit beide sind total lecker total möbel
der ist noch ein bisschen knuspriger des
ein bisschen weicher also schotter am
besten mal nach ich mag die ganz gerne
noch lauwarm die schmecken aber auch so
ein paar tage lang total lecker verpackt
sie einfach schön luftdicht und genießt
es gerne zu einer tasse kaffee kakao
oder milch die genauen mengenangaben zu
diesem rezept findet ihr wie jedes
andere auch hier unten in der infobox
und gerne könnt ihr wieder eure fotos
mit dem hashtag in sketchen auf
instagram zu senden
gerne könnt ihr mich auch hier
abonnieren dann verpasst ja auch nichts
mehr und die glocke aktivieren das ist
mal ganz praktisch dann bekommt ihr die
benachrichtigung klick darauf und seit
sofort der erste der mein neues video
schaut ich freue mich wenn ihr auch im
nächsten mal wieder einschaltet und sagt
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]